it took you by surprise you know I know
it rocked me over I didn't just take me
by surprise it rocked me
that's Gayle King speaking out on the
Kobe Bryant backlash a couple of weeks
ago you all might have here at Gayle was
disparage trolled attacked it was a very
challenging time hard to for me as a
friend in a one-on-one interview with
best friend Oprah Winfrey she reflected
on last month's controversy just it just
made me see that help comes from
unexpected places you know I always try
to operate from the do no harm
I always that is always my intention
when you talk about do no harm that was
certainly my intention doing that story
and doing that interview but what God to
me was that vitriol and the vulgarity
that was just unleashed at me in ways
that I couldn't even understand where
that was coming from the onstage
interview took place Saturday as part of
Oprah's 20/20 vision your life InFocus
tour but it certainly was it was a
learning curve and it was very painful
but yeah I think sometimes you have to
go through that that makes you question
things in life Gayle was criticized
after her interview with Kobe Bryant's
friend Lisa Leslie on CBS this morning
an out-of-context clip from that
interview about Kobe's 2003 sexual
assault allegation instigated a
widespread social media backlash is it
even a fair question to talk about it
considering he's no longer with us and
that it was resolved or is it really
part of his history Gayle was also
called out by Snoop Dogg on Instagram he
okay out of pocket for that we expect
more from you Gayle don't you hang out
with Oprah why are y'all attacking us
the rapper later posted an apology and
opened up about his profanity filled
video on read.table talk I wanted to
make sure that what I said was said the
right way and I want to make sure that
the message was across that we love Kobe
and be respectful of Vanessa those kids
yes that's what the whole it
right to protect that woman and them
babies over there because she's still
grieving
yeah and let's give them that respect in
the days that followed Oprah defended
her best friend of many years you know I
was on the phone with her this morning I
was on the phone with her last night I
was on the phone with her the night
before this is very hard because when
you have social media and the force of
social media and particularly people who
didn't see either interview making
attacks in a backstage video Oprah
posted to Instagram and we all shared
her anxiety about the interview I was so
nervous
why why why I can't believe this Gayle I
said Gayle I got you to just like I'm so
nervous I got you I got you but still
Oprah that's the first time that I've
talked about it out loud yeah Oprah
wrote alongside the video quilt can
y'all believe that after 40 years of
friendship Gayle King was worried about
being interviewed by me but there's no
one else I'd rather end Oprah's 20/20
vision tour than with my bestie
[Music]